jean hugues anglade bonsoir timbre est
d'abord à toutes les filles qui me
disent toujours dans cette émission il
est super gonzesses
il n'y a jamais de beau mais quand je
signale qu'à lui samuel le bihan il ya
jean hugues anglade baladeur ban a su
comment ça va très bien merci
il est déjà malaise à peine il arrive ya
déjà un malaise bien alors jean hugues
anglade
en plus vous vous êtes vous avez une
qualité c'est qu'on peut dire que vous
vous êtes pas beaucoup de problèmes pour
mettre tout nu parce que j'ai en prêt
commence fort non mais au printemps 80
en clôture du conservatoire vous êtes nu
sur scène dans tête d'or de claudel déjà
commencé très fort dès l'école quoi oui
et vous n'avez jamais eu tellement de
problèmes en fait j'ai pas de saper j'ai
pas de problème pour me pour me montrer
nue vas-y là il se dit alors est-ce
qu'ils vont demander le pas tout de
suite à la fin à la fin de l'émission à
dix mois
votre premier film dont 82 ça s'appelait
l'indiscrétion de pierre larry et vous
aimez pas en parler pourquoi
non c'était parce que c'était 2
j'étais comme un jeune acteur assez
j'avais le trac et ça n'a pas été fait
sa part été un film qui l'est qui s'est
déroulée dans le plaisir
ouais le premier film vous considérez
que c'est quoi c'est l'homme blessé
l'homme blessé cette année d'après 183
patrice chéreau à vous avez une carrière
étonnante vous avez fait plein de films
en fait donc l'homme blessé qu'un film
très très sensible très beau en 85
subway de besson en 86 évidemment 37 2
le matin de beineix déjà 89 une
magnifique d'alain corneau nocturne
indien 90 nikita besson 94 kg donc aussi
la même année la reine margot toujours
chéreau et en 96 vous écrivez vous
réalisez ton cas avec votre compagne de
l'époque pamela sous vous avez rencontré
alors sainement vous l'avez rencontré
six ans avant de faire le film
alors que vous devez signer le
personnage c'est incroyable cette
histoire oui j'avais déjà commencé à
écrire les premiers traits du personnage
est effectivement par une coïncidence
assez heureux je les rencontrais de deux
ans après le début de mon écriture c'est
fou ça bah oui je sais pas si c'est fou
en tout cas c'est bien vous arrivé un
soir aux bains douches
oui c'est votre personnage est là devant
vous oui ça a dû vous faire un choc
ça m'a fait ça m'a fait bizarre mais
j'étais j'étais conquis oui et après le
film la question qui vient à l'esprit
dans ces cas là c est ce qu après le
film une fois le film terminé
est-ce que l'existant encore où est ce
que c'était simplement le personnage du
film et puis voilà le film terminé je
crois qu'elle existait par certains
traits de son caractère toujours mais le
après je me suis marié avec elle et et
voilà j'ai récemment divorcée donc
pouvoir n'aime pas parler sa vie privée
ça dure bah oui voilà c'est c'est tous
et ses finalités de la fin d'une belle
aventure mais et de niro l'avait draguer
à calan 94 me souviens que j'étais le
dernier au courant d'ailleurs c'était à
l'époque de la deûle à delà de la reine
margot mais je m'en suis pas vraiment
rendu compte et je crois en plus que les
que les journaux à scandale les journaux
assez facile ont un peu quand même
amplifié wii ne s'est rien passé
rassurez-nous je crois non je ne crois
pas bon ou bien alors maintenant il ya
effectivement ma fille laurent pour jean
x le fais parce que je les aime bien
vas-y mortel transfert donc de beineix
avec hélène de fougerolles yves rénier
formidable dans le film robert hirsch
catherine mouchet et denis podalydès qui
fait l'inspecteur de police au passage
j'aimerais vous remercie vous remercier
parce que toute l'équipe est très
touchée vous défendiez le film puisque
vous avez déjà invité hélène de
fougerolles way pour en parler
aujourd'hui où l'invité non mais c'est
un film qu'on aime bien très contente
c'est pas un film facile parce que c'est
vrai qu'au chaigne à linge à son jeu
serait bien qu'il ya même des murs du
sang ici
c'est génial et
excellent autant c'est d'autant mieux
qu'en fait pas un film c'est pas comme
le dit matin cela ne se vérifie pas la
seconde près un film ça demande du temps
pour s'installer et que là on est en
train d'assister à un retour de devin de
tendance est bien bon bouche à oreille
c'est vrai qu'au départ après ça a été
un peu comme ça mais on n'a pas vraiment
et dice est vrai que malgré tout le film
maintenant est en train de de bain de
marquer des points et on est très on est
très confiants et jean-jacques on va se
battre jusqu'au bout pour que le film
existe mais c'est un petit soldat
beineix à tous les matins il part au
combat lien oui c'est même un grand
soldat nouvelle belgique d'où ce jeu
[Musique]
à
ah ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
noah
[Musique]
mortel transfert de jean jacques beineix
avec jean hugues anglade qui est notre
invité ce soir
alors vous jouez le rôle de michel
durand un psychanalyste et une vie
plutôt banale déjà en train de recevoir
des clients il ya catherine boucher qui
fait une prof de maths chahuté qui est
excellente dans le rôle d'ailleurs puis
à l'éjaculation précoce qui est toujours
énervé et puis lé récit sado-maso de
d'hélène de fougerolles donc qui joue
olga kugler et qui est une perverse
cleptomane qu'elle se faire battre par
son mari qui yves rénier voilà et que se
passe-t-il que ça oui j'avais oublié un
peu un site de l'émission
il se passe que à ce psychanalyste est
quand même un peu dépressif et il est
absolument convaincu que cette cette
patiente et said éveillé en lui des
désirs meurtrier et il a la fâcheuse
tendance à s'endormir quand elle vient
le consulter et un jour il s'endort elle
se réveille et elle est morte sur son
divan est il à d'horribles douleur dans
les avants droit donc voilà alors
peut-on assez signer quelqu'un
endormante c'est la première question
qu'on se pose et ensuite comme l'a très
vite comment se débarrasser du corps
oui et donc toute une histoire commence
une histoire effectivement très ça fait
un peu penser aux films de deux scores
cc qui s'appelait after hours rivière de
type il est pris dans une espèce de
d'engrenages comme ça c'est un peu cet
esprit la guayi absolument il aurait la
possibilité d'appeler tout de suite à
police est finalement il fait le mauvais
choix ou le bon choix en donnant
finalement à l'arrivée on s'aperçoit que
ce film c'est aussi le parcours
initiatique d'un psy dame si au fond qui
qui va régler des comptes avec lui mais
elle en fait son analyse à lui parce que
tu pourrais petit il faut avoir fait une
analyse mais lui son analyse qu'au début
du tout comment ça finit bien final près
il est obligé de regarder les problèmes
qu'ils n'avaient pas réglé les actes -
c'est ça c'est ça l'histoire tout à fait
vous ai fait une psy ou n'ont jamais non
non vous et l envoi rollin pour préparer
le film
oui enfin j'ai vu que j'ai pu j'ai vu
peu de gens j'ai vu une personne qui m'a
donné deux phrases clés qui l'écoutent
flottante et la neutralité bienveillante
non mais en fin de compte je sais il a
été il a fait rue keller et müller
non j'ai pas vu me l'air bon non j'en ai
rencontré un beaucoup plus intéressant
et et
madame
métras lite et bienveillante et écoute
flottante voilà ça c'est le b à ba du
psy ces prix en fête du travail avec
l'acteur vis-à-vis de ses personnages
alors votre père était vétérinaire et
finalement vous avez intégré un peu
inconsciemment les codes du en voyant ça
peut-être non les codes du patient des
malades etc
oui si élégant qui vont jusqu'à les
mavericks avoir justement et qu'on
manquait de costumes j'avais choper des
monts bref ça je ne pouvais pas te le
dire je vous ai déjà fait des rôles de
médecins faisaient déjà fait j'ai dis
moi oui
gilbert canabady d'amour de doré et donc
vous avez est ce que ça vient de voler
vers la cité les animaux avec leur avec
leurs maîtres et puis j'en ai conçu
surtout une très très grande passion
pour le monde animal j'adore les alliés
arabes
là vous avez quelqu'un sait que laurent
alors on the au fil c'est incroyable
comment on dit quelqu'un qui aime bien
les animaux grâce à ses ciseaux
philologue mais alors j'en rigole la
dhuys et les félins oui c'est les
guépards oui c'est connu c'est le
guépard longchamp du guépard tout le
monde connaît même fait tatouer déconner
tu vas devoir à laon à la hanche là on a
dit on a dit à la fin venus y en a et
les filles à la fin de l'émission jean
hugues anglade ou bon si vous suivez
toujours
si vous êtes plus jour là vous verrez le
guépard de gens rigolent bien alors vous
allez retrouver hélène de fougerolles
que vous aviez déjà vu dans trois
légendes de jardin elle a de l'avenir
vous pensé parce que tout le monde lui
prédit un grand avenir mais en même
temps elle n'a pas encore trouvé le
parce que là elle meurt vite dans la
route de bélaye c'est quelqu'un qui a
l'audace pour pouvoir effectivement
brasser des idées des personnages
difficile et et voilà donc elle est un
peu l est au début mais on avait pas mal
mais elle est très audacieuse elle donne
accès du mal avec elle quand même parce
que là pas voulu a voulu rien montré oui
ella ella
la négocier ouais mais je pense que
c'est se montrer nue n'est pas forcément
un signe d'extraversion la preuve en est
c'est que moi je suis pas
particulièrement fâché plutôt timide de
nature timide et très facilement jouer
et je me suis mis deux nuls en déficit
mais vous avez une plastique
exceptionnel bien alors vous avez
retrouvé beineix assez intéressant parce
que 37 2 le matin ce com était un film
c'est toujours un film culte
vous l'avez retrouvé comment oui bah je
vais retrouver par hasard c'est lui qui
m'a appelé 15 ans après un nom que j'ai
gardé un tel souvenir de 37,2 bon c'est
une banalité de que de le dire encore
aujourd'hui met d'ailleurs en j'en
profite pour dire que le dvd en version
intégrale intégrale de 37,2 va sortir là
est déjà sorti je pense ce que j'ai
appris sur sur mortel transfert est
davantage
j'ai davantage regarder jean jacques et
la façon dont il avait évolué la façon
dont il s'était aguerris et puis la
maturité qui est la sienne aujourd'hui
son indépendance son courage parce qu'il
faut pas oublier que ce fait mais c'est
lui qui l'a produit encore une fois
c'est vraiment très courageux et c'est
encore la raison pour laquelle je pense
que la critique et la critique était
très dur avec lui parce que elle devrait
tenir compte de la courage qui a été le
sien de produire ce film humaniste en
argent il aimait son argent et sa wii
pour une fois qu'un producteur qui
minent son argent à lui c'est tellement
il ya un peu d'argent de canal est un
peu d'argent allemands bondissent en
ville a mis beaucoup d'argent à lui
voilà alors vous quand vous parlez de
votre travail
c'est vrai que c'est très différent d'un
film sur le route et vous dites j'ai pas
une petite valise remplie de recettes et
j'ai pas encore trop de combines je fais
le maximum pour rester vierge face à un
rôle c'est vrai que c'est pas marqué
dans un type de rôle particulier non non
je suis prof d'un rédacteur de me dirai
enfin je ne crois pas non mais c'est pas
trop pas moi de le dire
ah bon je vous la nouvelle qui pour le
dire non mais c'est à dire que c'est
c'est un métier très
très empirique c'est une approche très
très atypique c'est très difficile et
aussi passionnant bien alors ça
s'appelle mortel transfert de jean
jacques beineix avec hélène de
fougerolles jean hugues anglade et c'est
dans un cinéma près de chez vous
comme vous faites le comme vous faites
le psy dans le film ben vous allez avoir
droit à une interview psy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez bougé oui je vous dit tout sur
cette émission avait pourtant je la suis
un bon rallume
non ça le rend que vous avez été
exemplaire tu toi au moins tu as été
exemplaire vous citiez
attention interruption on bouge pas
pendant le guignol bonne réponse de rien
nous où je réponds à caroline qui n'ont
rien email en dix ans fait toujours
l'interview psy à des filles banon je la
fais un garçon et c'est beaucoup plus
excitant
est ce que vous êtes parano par exemple
la bnf quand il a lancé son fils me l'a
dit la chasse aux beineix est ouverte
alors tout le monde à les mélanger pas
de chasse aux beineix et personne ne l'a
vu encore donc c'est un peu de la parano
est ce que vous vous êtes un peu comme
ça à croire que tout le monde vous
déteste c'est tout non non non non je
pense pas non non non mais par rapport à
jean jacques je pense que il ya des gens
qui l'attendait au cou avec un couteau
quand même avait quand même c'est que
c'est vrai mais non je sais quelle
raison la main je pense au contraire
même qu'il a été très subtil très très
spirituel paramore d'accord à cette
phrase excuse et de ce qu'ils au nom
claustro oui c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs que je ne fais pas de théâtre
et
même au gymnase même ses prix le gymnase
s'est pris pour trois ans je vous êtes
exhibo oui non pas trop
vous n'êtes pas exhibo non pas tant que
ça magnéto serge vous êtes l'info oui
pas forcément que jamais j'aime me
tapait beaucoup de femmes mais j'aime
bien refaire plusieurs fois oui ça c'est
duracell salle fétiche au bois panaro à
chaque fois ça y est sadow non pas bon
non vous aimez pas danser les homos
vais-je été violée à l'âge de 13 ans par
un pédophile donc avant c'est vrai j'ai
du mal
dans ce cas là je savais pas ça mais non
personne ne le savait c'est et fils
après un vote je le dis je sois le recul
c'est pas c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
c'est bien c'est courageux de dire ça
si vous applaudissez trop ça va
encourager les pédophiles en même temps
ces courageuses qui fait exploser quoi
voulez qu'on arrête là parce que non
pourquoi non têtards d'eau oui ça
m'arrive
ouais c'est honteux comment peux tu mon
coco non ayrault non adamo oui mais
enfin il ya bien longtemps
bernardo 5-0 sur mu et jeunes ados bien
est-ce que vous êtes disco non jean
hugues anglade terre de janvier
avec hélène de fougerolles et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu